i think jack and uh mayor i think we
have both of you guys here
come on
yes sir bang bang
[Laughter]
so now listen this couldn't be more
exciting for me because we have the
mayor with obviously the the backdrop of
miami it's beautiful nice weather always
summer in miami summer fridays and then
we have jack who is in cold chicago in
an empty closet
still flexing though
all right so let's start with jack you
first talk to us about the pay me in
bitcoin feature that strike has rolled
out how does this work and why are
people using it it works just like a
direct deposit product is that when you
line up your paycheck you can go to
jpmorgan chase bank you could go to
chime you could go to strike and strike
allows you to toggle and convert any
percentage of your paycheck into bitcoin
so that the salary that you earn from
working a wage can be paid in half
dollars half bitcoin 75 bitcoin 25 100
bitcoin and the point in that is that
saving accounts are dead it costs more
for a bank to custody your dollars then
they'll give you yield so how do you
save money and can you get paid in
commercial real estate can you get paid
in precious metal gold bars and we
wanted a product for the individual
consumer to say hey i want to save my
non-working capital in bitcoin because
it's the best savings technology of all
time
and that's it it's really dead simple
you hand your form to your employer and
uh from then on out for the rest of
eternity you can get paid in bitcoin
whatever percentage you want now mayor
you obviously got into a uh a little
competition a good competition in my
opinion where you said that you were
gonna take your next paycheck in bitcoin
and then the mayor-elect in new york
city said oh yeah you're gonna do one
i'm gonna do three and then i think
you've come back over the top with i'm
gonna take all of my paychecks in
bitcoin so talk to us a little bit about
getting paid in bitcoin how you think
about it personally and then also the
potential to eventually do this with
other people within the city's uh
employee base
yeah so first of all you know a while
back uh you know i pledge that i wanted
to allow my employees to get paid in
bitcoin allow
residents to be able to pay for fees and
taxes in bitcoin which we're still
working on and then eventually
potentially hold bitcoin on our balance
sheet so we've accomplished step one
already uh our cio mike saurasi was the
first uh city of miami employee to use
strike and to be able to get paid in
bitcoin um i i said you know what i'm
gonna i gotta i gotta follow him i gotta
you know uh like jack would say you
gotta lead by example and uh you know
and so i decided to do it and then of
course eric adams i think the mayor of
tampa uh the mayor of jacksonville i
think uh uh jack was telling us up to
six mayors already across the united
states are taking uh either all or some
or some percentage in bitcoin their
salaries you know when i started talking
about a bitcoin in terms of uh you know
in terms of paying our employees a
percentage or whatever they want to like
like jack said it could be whatever
whatever they want right you know
bitcoin i think was like at 40 000. so
you know it's gone up 50
uh you know people talk a lot about the
volatility particularly people that
don't like bitcoin for whatever reason
they like to talk about the volatility
but they don't talk about the
year-over-year gains which is crazy i
don't understand how they can talk about
one thing without the other which is
really the more relevant statistic right
and so uh you know it's amazing and with
inflation certainly being underreported
as we all know um you know it's it's an
important hedge uh and it's becoming the
base currency for many many people
jack when you think about uh folks
getting paid in bitcoin this obviously
serves as uh kind of a de facto uh
dollar cost averaging right is every
every week uh every other week every
month whenever i get paid i'm just
converting into bitcoin talk a little
bit about the power of that and why
that's so important
yeah well first i didn't say happy
thanksgiving i'm on this show thankful
as [ __ ] right now the mayor the man and
the pomp brothers i hope everyone's
having a good holiday um
yeah all right so let's go on a little
bit of a rant um
inflation
uh six percent according to cpi uh but
housing is my favorite metric um because
everyone needs a roof over their head to
live uh 24 and a half percent in the
united states so let me
put this abundantly clear and not in uh
word salad speak if you
watching this are not getting a 25
raise every single year
housing is getting more expensive than
you are earning income so you are not
making progress towards owning a home
okay
that's a huge problem how many of you
you family your friends are getting a 25
raise every single year to keep up with
how expensive housing is getting and so
are you [ __ ]
no you just cannot save in dollars
that's a very known thing whether it's
housing your kids education vacation
cars everything that's a hard asset
that's hard to obtain is getting more
expensive than you can earn so you have
to change the way you save and what's
very unique about bitcoin pomp is it's
the most accessible savings technology
of all time traditionally you'd have to
buy a big chunk of real estate you'd
have to find a way to store gold you
know maybe the ken griffins of the world
the big hedge fund managers maybe those
guys can go get new york city manhattan
penthouses and store their wealth there
what about me what about the mayor's
employees what about the everyday
individual is there an accessible scarce
uh monetary policy that's predictable
that lives external of any central party
that we can even get a penny of our
paycheck in and yes it's bitcoin and so
for me the whole power of the product is
that you don't need to convince your cfo
you don't need to work for a special
company you don't need to be a hedge
fund manager this is an asset that works
in the best interest of everybody it has
no bias it doesn't care towards any
certain type of wealth class it is the
most fair free open savings technology
in human history
and so all we're doing is letting you
line up your direct deposit and you get
to decide what portion of your savings
should be allocated towards bitcoin but
pom what if i tried to build a payment
gold bars product or a payment
commercial real estate product get the
[ __ ] out of here it'd be impossible that
things natively digital it's divisible
into 100 million pieces you could store
it on your phone you could store it for
yourself it's an absolute no-brainer and
so we've got a dozen mayors we've got
nfl athletes we've got the biggest
musicians in the world but i also have
you want to know one of the biggest
companies of paycheck to our service
uber
you got guys that are trying to make a
living wage and outpace inflation and
work their way towards owning a home and
they're driving uber and an ability to
save to when the richest in the world
like michael saylor makes a buck the
uber driver makes a buck too and the
post mates delivery man right everyone
is in this together and so that it was
so intuitive to me of um let's just make
this as accessible as possible to the
people and allow them to outpace
inflation because inflation devastates
the poor more than the ken griffins in
the world it's really that simple mayor
suarez there's not very many people
who'd laid out better than jack does i
think that uh what he's been able to
build is obviously a very unique type of
product but talk to us about the
challenges right i you sent me a picture
or you tweeted a picture i remember
seeing a picture of you right after you
had gone uh and you looked exhausted
because you had gone and tried to
convince people to allow the employees
to get paid in bitcoin put bitcoin on
the balance sheet accept bitcoin for
payments like this is a very hard task
to do uh and there's a lot of
bureaucracy and there's a lot of kind of
rules that need to be changed or looked
at again so maybe just talk about like
the difficulty in doing that which i
think really highlights why strike
specifically allows people to get the
same direct deposit and auto convert it
into bitcoin rather than have to maybe
jump through kind of all the bureaucracy
that you're dealing with at the city
level
yeah well i i mean first of all i was
exhausted when i did that video uh it
was a thursday night uh and and you know
it wasn't like the ideal time to post a
video and the metrics which is another
thing that people understand people
don't understand how many people have
bitcoin or are part of this community
it's massive it's
far far far far far greater than what
people actually believe uh so that's
been a lesson to me that's been proven
time and time again but the the
resistance has has been plentiful i
remember when i first started talking
about bitcoin i had people telling me
you're going to ruin your career um this
is a ponzi scheme um you know stop
talking about it uh you know i i've had
all kinds of of people come to me and
and tell me all kinds of things and so
you know that that's part of it i think
the other part of it is there is a bit
of a generational uh issue uh my dad was
a really smart guy two graduate degrees
from harvard 72 years old mechanical
engineer um you know he struggles
understanding that concept because
remember they grew up in a gold back
based world right currency world to then
a a you know central back bank bank full
faith and credit world fiat world uh to
what we're going into now and so
it's it's it is an abstract paradigm
shift for them and then i think the
third thing is is that generation that
is struggling to understand it
is by and large the generation that's in
power i'm an anomaly i'm 44 years old
mayor of a big city i'm not the
prototypical guy you know what i mean
i'm i i'm i like to say that
i'm at an interesting inflection point
in my life i'm young enough to
understand new technology and old enough
to do something about it and so it's uh
it's it's a unique opportunity for me
which is why i think you know i've been
able to lead so much on this because i
get it and then it's just about
evangelizing it so uh it it hasn't been
easy um i've been blessed to have people
like you pomp and jack and others that
have created either products that are
supportive of it or or educated me on it
and giving me ideas on things that we
can do to keep you know the volume up
because i think a big part of this we've
talked about this from day one it's
almost been a year you know it's about
about mainstreaming something that we
know uh can empower so many people can
democratize investment for so many
people so uh it's been a an incredible
run we have some more exciting things
that we're gonna announce uh soon uh
you're gonna really like and i think
jack's gonna like too and uh it was
gonna keep the momentum going it's a lot
of fun
joe john what questions you guys got for
these guys
all right jack you got something go
ahead jack
yeah i just want to put it one more way
because i really want people to
understand this [ __ ]
if 25 percent you over your this is my
favorite way i explained to a family
yesterday
25 year-over-year inflation for housing
that means compounded over the next
three to five years housing will double
so if you hold dollars
your house your dream home that you got
bookmarked on zillow is gonna get 25
more expensive every single year and
doubly as expensive every three to five
years now if you hold bitcoin what are
the bitcoin metrics bitcoin is averaging
appreciation of over 100 percent year
every year so that means everything
around you if you hold bitcoin is
getting
half off
every single year
so your dream home which was a million
bucks
and then was 1.25 and then five years
later two million dollars decade laters
double five million dollars is getting
more expensive dream home in bitcoin
used to be ten thousand bitcoin then it
was a thousand bitcoin and it's 500
bitcoin a lot of people's dream home in
america is less than 100 bitcoin less
than 50 bitcoin and four years from now
it's probably less than that so what
asset do you want to hold and save and
if you hold dollars your life gets more
expensive at a shocking rate if you hold
bitcoin it's half off all year round
baby
it's half off your whole life you don't
got to do [ __ ]
black friday in perpetuity
so i'll leave you with that all right
what question you guys got i love it and
i love the energy you're bringing jack
that's just what we needed um
i sent him some cuban coffee from miami
to chicago
trust me he doesn't need any more coffee
i don't know what he puts in his veins
every day
he's like ready to just flick everybody
off and get to work all right what
questions this is good uh jack so you
were talking earlier about uh the mayors
obviously the celebrities the athletes
the entertainers who are using this
product uh and understand kind of what
using bitcoin as a savings account can
do but as someone who has been working
on this for a long period of time and
talked to a lot of retail traders or
kind of just everyday blue-collar
workers have those conversations changed
are more people understanding this are
more people looking for this solution
just talk through kind of what you're
seeing on that side
yeah i think inflation is a trending
topic right now i think um
whoever the the central banks the nation
state your local government everyone's
kind of lost pulse and grasp of of the
narrative i think the narrative is in
the hands of the people right now and
there's a lot of speculation whether
that's because of covid there's just a
general distrust in the authority period
in your boss in your local government
and you're i mean it is um and so i
think people are genuinely scared um
and i and i think it actually is a
really concerning time for the market at
large i think the federal reserve has
perverted risk tolerance across all
assets and you're seeing [ __ ] like shiba
unucoin trade at premiums and that's
really sad it's because people are
fleeing for the exits and they don't
know where to run and they don't know
where to hide and i think it's scary and
so i think it is my job to try and guide
people and give them accessible tools to
what we believe is right which is the
sound safe and principled savings
technology and that conversation has
extended to the biggest athletes in the
world there's a a very popular golfer
who tees off at 4pm eastern that may get
get that paycheck in bitcoin so really
prime time folks to my neighbors i mean
every it's a problem we all face is if
you have capital that you intend to save
how do you save it um
and
so um the numbers i'm seeing on my
dashboard we just hit an all-time high
today
in the payday direct deposit metrics i
mean it goes up every single day um
so i don't know if that answered your
question but uh yeah i i i'll say this
it is uniquely a problem that everyone
in the world faces um it is money is the
most viral product of all time and it's
a product that will perpetually be in
demand and so
it's weird that the president of el
salvador aaron rodgers and the guy that
dropped me off at my thanksgiving with
uber are all cheering for each other and
all trying to solve the same problem i
don't know the last time that that was a
real thing and that that was the case um
and so
yeah that's my answer john
yeah thanks jack and uh mayor swears for
joining us today so my question would be
mayor swears can you just talk about the
regulation and kind of what's going on
in that conversation if you've heard
anything that uh is either just good or
bad and what you think about regulation
in general in the space
yeah i mean i so what i think about
regulation is that we have to be very
careful as a country china has given us
a tremendous gift
by banning bitcoin and banning mining um
which which will allow us to do it in an
esg friendly way most miners in america
that i've talked to that i've spoken
with are esg conscious or or carbon
neutral so this esg
uh issue has i think been overblown um
for a variety of reasons we could do a
whole show on that but i think that's
something that as a as a community we
need to communicate better uh because
look there's a lot of threats uh uh to
bitcoin there's a lot of people that
feel threatened by bitcoin and so it's
important that a we all communicate
continue to communicate continue to
build our platforms uh b
we have to evangelize to the generation
that right now is still predominantly in
power and that generation
doesn't quite understand it doesn't
quite know what to do with it they kind
of see a lot of the good they realize
how many people are getting it and i
think that's that's a big part of it but
i think they're also afraid you know
look in this country we uh quote unquote
protect people
um from themselves right and so what
does that mean that means oftentimes
we're stripping away
the ability for people to make money on
the under the premise that we don't want
them to be defrauded and so nobody wants
to be defrauded we don't want people to
be defrauded but at the same time if you
take away people's ability to risk
capital you're taking away their ability
to make a return and so that's something
that as as bitcoin uh you know becomes
more and more prevalent and and of other
kinds of of crypto technology you know
we have to really be conscientious of it
uh you know uh you know when people are
able to take their bitcoin and get four
percent seven percent yield ten percent
yield i mean you know you're getting the
appreciation that john
uh talks about but you're not only
getting the appreciation you're also
getting a yield an interest yield on top
of the appreciation right so you know
there is no other financial product as
he said that that gives that there's
none and then and so the question is are
we as a society and as a country going
to stifle innovation or are we gonna
lead into this new what i call
technological industrial revolution
right by embracing the kinds of
technologies that are going to create
financial freedom for more and more
americans in a democratized fashion by
the way it's incredibly democratized not
just for americans for central america
south america obviously we see what's
happening with el salvador or panama's
looking at it a lot of countries in
south america and africa so i think
ironically the the underdeveloped
country or
some would argue as a third world
country they're the ones that really
stand to benefit the most when you look
at the inflation rates in those
countries
i mean
there are like 50 and above right i mean
they're crazy crazy inflation rates so
you know i think i saw venezuela was
like 5 000 or something i i don't
remember the exact number but it was a
crazy percentage obviously it's a
communist country so they just print
their money and and deflate their
currency and that's the problem the
problem is you have human beings
controlling these institutions and
they're they're making public policy on
the basis of what's best for them as
individuals not what's best for their
country and that's why uh people are are
you know fleeing uh fiat currencies left
and right and and becoming more and more
uh bitcoin holders uh you know across
the world
well said i completely agree mayor
swears
mayor you don't know this yet but uh
john has told me and he's told people on
this show that uh he's waiting for you
to decide to run for governor or
president or decide what your next
career move is and then if you'd be so
kind he'll just go ahead and take over
as mayor he's got some ideas come visit
my office next week
listen
we we need good people in public service
i think that's something that our
generation i think now when we see this
bitcoin debate and we see how regulation
can stifle iteration that can hurt
people right it makes you really really
appreciate why it's necessary to have
good people in public service so i
definitely think you know getting in
public service is something that i
totally recommend it's a hard business
um it's not easy uh you have to have
fixed in i know all of you guys do but
um you know but but but i recommend it
because we're listen we're a billion
dollar business we're a billion dollar
entity with 4 500 employees for labor
unions and all the international
problems imaginable so it's it's not an
easy easy thing to do but we need your
people to do it i appreciate you in the
way you have represented the people of
miami i think you've done it very well
all right last question and then i'll
let you two go jack talk to us about
twitter tips that seems to have exploded
uh i think you and i were sending money
back and forth to each other yesterday
as a messaging service what's going on
with uh with twitter tips and how that's
going
uh it's going well i think um
listen bitcoin is a monetary network
it's the only inherently global um
accessible asset monetary network in
human history um and so internet
companies there's going to be a
tremendous amount of demand for internet
companies to service monetary products
to their users twitter has 500 million
active daily users and they're all over
the world how do you sell them a
monetary experience without bitcoin uh
and you know what they i think the more
important narrative problem we've talked
about this offline is what they started
um now every internet company and every
big companies call my phone um and so no
it's going well why would it not you
have instant free global cash final
payments and tips um and so we're
working with twitter on how to make sure
that that can be outside of just our
service we don't want to be the only one
supporting and and how they can make it
extensible to everyone in the world uh
and then i'm working with other
companies on how to plug in there's a
world not far from now
where your twitter can tip someone on
instagram your instagram account can tip
someone on tick tock my tick tock
account go check out and buy my
starbucks and what does that tell you
that tells you that there's a singular
monetary protocol that can achieve
settlement cheaper faster and more
global than anything else we've ever
seen the last time we saw that form of
consolidation in any industry was the
internet the internet is free instant
global communication for the world
there's not many internet spam there's
one
the bitcoin and lightning network is
free instant global monetary settlement
for the world and there's not going to
be 250 of them there's going to be one
and we're starting to see that
consolidation for money as a service and
as a product and so twitter was the
first it won't be the last it's going
well
i uh i appreciate it
can we get a little pawn to e4 just for
the people
there's a chess board back there you
want me to get up and move the pawn no
no no no no all right listen i
appreciate both of you obviously uh jack
you're doing a fantastic job with strike
mayor you've you've done a fantastic job
as well uh continue to push this forward
so well we will definitely continue to
bring you guys back but uh thank you
guys so much for taking time out of your
uh your weekend to do this and uh as as
we continue to say just pay me and
bitcoin in the world will be a better
place so i appreciate both of them